hey what's up guys my name is a China
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we talked about time steps and
dental time and all the kind of timing
things that we needed to talk about
definitely check out that video if you
haven't already and we actually are
moving towards kind of a complete little
minor kind of system that we have from
making 2d renderable kind of objects and
interaction and weld games I guess
alright because what we have at the
moment is we've got a camera system a
little camera system we've got ways to
kind of submit geometry for rendering
we've got the ability to like respond to
key presses and all of that kind of
stuff and move like well not move
objects yet but just move the actual
camera and do all that fun stuff who are
a proper kind of renderer flow right so
the next step in kind of continuing on
with this trend is how do we place
objects in different places in our world
right so at the moment we only have the
ability to put all the objects at stuff
like if the objects will be rendered
according to their vertex positions
right so we have like we're rendering a
triangle where we're entering a square
or a rectangle it's a square
used to be a rectangle because of the
projection matrix but now the square so
we're entering all of them kind of at
the origin on all really like it doesn't
have to be the origin is whatever the
vertex positions like say that's where
it gets rendered but what I want to do
and what you know we need to be able to
do is actually say that I want to render
this object with a particular transform
right and that's actually that transform
is something called like a model matrix
essentially it's like a world matrix
which describes like the position the
rotation and the transfer sorry the
position the rotation the scale so the
transform of the actual entity in the 3d
world that it's in right and that's
primarily how objects get put into their
respective places in the world right we
have that like if we look at this Bunny
for example right we have this kind of
bunny this is our 3d model so the actual
bunny is made up of various vertex
positions and other vertex attributes
right like normals you know texture
coordinates that kind of stuff but all
of these vertex positions such as
relative to each other right they're not
relative to where it is in the world you
know
I couldn't put the bunny here I could
put the bunny here right however that's
not gonna it's not gonna that's not
gonna have any that shouldn't have any
kind of effect on the actual vertex
positions why because we kind of when we
model the bunny we model it like at the
origin maybe or just on top of the
origin so it's like on a ground plane
like that we build up all of it or all
the vertices and that's kind of the
bunny that we end up with right and then
when we actually render it inside a 3d
world we apply an additional
transformation to those vertices which
tells how computer we're in the world we
want to actually render this bunny right
that way we can use the same bunny model
if we want to render something here or
there right if we if we actually wanted
to only render according to FedEx
positions we'd have to modify the values
the FedEx buff for the bunny or create
two different bunny objects or models or
two different bunny vertex buffers
because we want we want one bunny here
and one bunny here that's um what we
want we want to render the exact same
set of vertices however we actually want
to transform that set of vertices by a
certain amount right whether it be
translation which is where it is in the
world rotation which is how its kind of
rotated or oriented and then scale so
how kind of big or small it is right all
of that is a transformation matrix and
we need one of them for every single
object that we really want to render and
in the grand scheme of things most game
engines use something called an AC as an
inter component system or like some kind
of for like form of composable game
objects but basically we have kind of a
set of components and they are composed
together into like essentially a game
object right so if we look at like an NC
component system what that basically
says is that everything is a component
right and we have a certain data a set
of Java research and then we have a
bunch of systems associated with that as
well that's eventually what hazel will
have some form of ECS source or cg or
something like that right but until
that's the case because in that scenario
then the transform will actually be a
component that's probably like like it
is in most engines mandated to be on all
objects doesn't have to be because you
can you know
you think about it an NCO game object
could be something that doesn't actually
even get rendered and in that in that
form it might not need to have it like a
transform or anything like that but for
everything that's get gets rendered will
have a transform component which is
where that data is stored we don't have
that at the moment I'm going to put this
bunny down I think but we don't have
that at the moment so what we have
instead is just this kind of hazel
render a submit call that takes in a
shader that takes in a vertex array
that's what we're going to take in a
transform so we're basically saying I
want this mesh which has a material
which is our shader at the moment and
our vertex array which is our geometry
at the moment they'll eventually be
collapsed into just one mesh object we
we want to submit that and we want to
render it at a particular transform and
of course transforms have to be per mesh
right there have to be per object they
can't be for the whole scene
our cameras transform is usually for the
whole scene right that's what we talked
about in the cameras video but for
actual meshes for 3d objects of a render
we need a separate transform for each
kind of object that's why it's kind of
put into that section of the code anyway
this is cool because we're going through
my creating almost kind of low-level
kind of stuff that eventually that's is
gonna be so abstract that you guys love
no idea how it's gonna work
like I promise you like what's gonna
happen is that Hazel's API will change
so much I mean we're doing so much stuff
in even C++ now that will never be done
in C++ in the future we'll have a level
editor it will serialize certain files
those files will be read on startup
that's how our objects will be created
it'll be so like hard to understand how
hazel works that are really I'm happy
with the way that I'm kind of explaining
all this and taking time to actually set
this up in this kind of way even though
it is somewhat temporary and I'm not
obviously not running final engine code
straight away because I would be
basically impossible and really boring
to do what I'm doing is I'm actually
showing you guys how everything works
and that's I think that's really cool
because seeing an engine kind of work
from this phase before you start like
creating an ECS and doing all that stuff
first of all it helps to understand why
we even need an ICS and actually what
the ECS in the end of the day at the end
of day is going to do
because it's really gonna do the same
thing that we're doing here it's just
gonna be an in a much more abstract and
powerful way right muffled flexible way
whereas this kind of just tied down a
little bit better anyway let's jump in
let's take a look at the transformation
matrix and how we can actually render
our triangle and a square at different
transforms and one thing one other thing
that I want to say is that even though
it might appear that we're rendering 2d
objects in this case I mean obviously
our oldest rendering is kind of 3d and
the theory behind all everything I'm
explaining like you know meshes you know
materials bird x-rays
you know transforms all that stuff this
is really applicable to a three to a 3d
renderer if we build a 2d renderer we
would do it differently right
like we wouldn't have a material system
for example whenever we really have a
material system but we wouldn't be
submitting geometry with shaders right
for example we wouldn't do we just
wouldn't be doing that because it all
pretty much all the geometry would
actually have a single shader right it's
like it would be like our 2d material
shader right and then also we wouldn't
be you know just like a lot of the way
that this stuff is written is
specifically for 3d right like we
wouldn't be it wouldn't be submitting a
transform either so no sure there's no
transforms none of that because what
what actually happens is when you when
your request to draw like a to be
primitive like a square you know
basically everything until you direct 2d
rendering is going to come down to being
like a quad when you actually do draw a
quad in a 2d system you you'd actually
batch that into like a big vertex buffer
with other causes that you want to
render so that you can do it all in one
draw call with one shader right whereas
with 3d kind of rendering you typically
I mean you can batch things together
obviously and you can try and sort
things into a particular render order so
that you kind of group things together
so everything with this material should
get around at the same time but in
general you basically render every
object with a separate transform and a
separate material potentially right
whereas in tune it's very different so
this might look today but just keep in
mind that this theory is all applicable
to 3d and in fact when we do touch on
specifically 2d rendering and hazel
which we haven't done yet at that point
in time that's what I'll kind of explain
I guess more of the differences and also
how it would do this in today before we
jump to the code I want to give a huge
thank you to all the patrons patron 4/2
Turner is where you can go
to help support the series you'll get
rewarded by like just getting videos
early and also getting access to like
group discussions in which we talk about
the future hazel and all that stuff and
also access to the hazel development
ranch which is my kind of private
developing branch for hazel in which
I've basically done all of this stuff
and more pbrn rain 3d rendering really
cool stuff that's based like a full
level editor there right there's a cold
while your viewer and everything and you
can even just plug in your own textures
using UI and there's a lot of stuff you
can do so definitely check that out and
help support the series let's drop in
and take a look at model matrices and
transforms and all that stuff ok so as I
mentioned we have this kind of big
insane we have this kind of submit and
then we have an end scene that's kind of
the actual floor of our renderer so what
we actually want to do now is upon
submission we need to position our
object in the world so what we're going
to do is basically plug in some kind of
transformation matrix as a third
parameter into here so the way we'll do
that is we'll go to submit and then
inside my submission here I'm going to
add a third parameter this is going to
be constant um Matt for transform ok
that's it it's just gonna be a transform
matrix figure over here to submit we'll
add that in ok and then what's gonna
happen is very very simple just the same
way that we kind of submit this or we
upload this view projection matrix right
we're gonna do the exact same thing
every time we submit with the model
matrix now here's the difference so over
here I'm uploading the uniform matte 4
which is our V projection matrix into
and 2 into this shader for every single
submission whereas I don't actually need
to be doing that I only need to really
do that once per shader per scene right
so that's kind of this does not need to
be done every time it's done every time
at the moment because we're gonna have
any kind of global State and also we're
using two different shaders now anyway
and they do have to be updated but if
you're kind of using a single shader or
a single kind of material across all
these things you can actually just
upload that uniform at for once and then
render all the objects as separate draw
calls without having to update that but
with this one we actually like with this
model
matrix-like right so I'll call it you
underscore model matrix this actually
does need to be I don't know like I call
it model matrix transform might make
more sense to be honest so I'm actually
gonna call it transform I wasn't
planning to but I just did what we're
gonna do is submit this transform into
here right so this needs to be done per
object every time we submit we
absolutely need to do that now in a
renderer that doesn't render things
immediately like this and actually does
cue it up
you'd probably copy this actual
transformation matrix into like in 64
bytes you copy those 64 bytes into some
kind of buffer that would basically kind
of be like part of your render command
because typically when you render again
3d objects right you want to actually
render them at a transform that's normal
that's how rendering works so if we go
back to sandbox app and what we could do
again is just by default you know if I
go to the header file by default I'm
just going to set this to GL m mat for
one right and what this can do is just
basically give us the identity matrix
which means no transformation matrix
right it's not it's gonna be it's gonna
apply no transforms the same as
multiplying with one right so that we
don't have to necessarily submit a
transform if we don't want to and that
way like if I was to just launch this
code right now as is without actually
adding a transform it should render and
we should get the same results before
and I mean obviously I haven't even set
up any of the actual uniform so that's
probably gonna be useless doing this so
let's go ahead and set that up now right
so we have I'm scared of this so we have
our P projection and then we're just
gonna copy that
and I'm gonna make that we're gonna have
our you honest will transform right and
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
multiply boot projection by transform
and then by our bed exposition right so
it is adding that in and we'll do the
same so I'll copy this and add that into
our blue shader vertex source right so
we have this obviously inside our vertex
shader and so now we have the view
projection matrix and the transformation
matrix being multiplied together with
the
actual vertex position okay so that
should now give us I mean we should test
this right now with absolutely no
transform and make sure that we have the
same result as before but it was just
kind of like the square and triangle in
the kind of same position all right so
if we do that yeah we've got that and
then we can move the camera and we can
rotate the camera and everything works
in the same way so what I'll do now is
I'll actually plug in a matrix so
because I'm going to want to actually
play around with this and not just have
an boring old matrix in in here what I
want to do is actually make the matrix
over here so we have the camera position
that's all great but I also want to have
a little transform which I'll call
square maybe transform all right which
and this thing is actually going to be
actually you know what I'm just going to
make a Veck three instead called square
position right and I think I can just by
default set that over here to zero
because we need to initialize it and
then what I'll do is so left right up
down that moves the camera right what I
might do is just make the eye
JKL keys because like a and Dee's
already taken of rotation and I want to
mess with that but what I want to do is
I'm going to be basically copied as if
statement and implemented for the left
will be J right will be L I will be up
and down will be K so the the ijkl case
right I want to take those and make them
actually move our square position so now
we should be able to move the square
which will be quite cool I think so
we're gonna move it by so it's got
camera move speed which is like fine but
I think what I'll do is I'll copy that
and I'll just make a variable called
square moves paid and I'll just set it
to like one we'll make it quite slow so
we'll say square moves speed over here
square move speed and of course we need
to multiply it with Delta time as well
and now we have square positions so now
we're ready to make the matrix okay so
what I'll do is I'll say jello mat for
transform equals G LLB translate and
then we can just literally put in our
square position and that's it I mean
should provide a matrix that we want to
transform square position okay cool
right and that should just work right
now for translate we'll need um I think
we we did this inside camera so let's
just grab yeah we need this include to
make that happen so we'll just paste
that in there and now this should just
work right so I can just render my
square with out particular transform so
let's go ahead and just run that and see
what happens
so now if we use the ijkl keys we should
be able to actually move our square
around which should be cool and you can
see I can do that right and because it's
moving separately from the triangle now
if I move the camera it's gonna move
both of them right it's gonna move them
the kind of opposite way whereas this
will just kind of move it like that so
that's really really cool now here's
what I can do this pretty cool as well I
can actually rent a whole bunch of these
so at the moment we're just rendering
just one square and it's actually quite
big but what I could do is actually use
this to render some kind of tile based
system right now obviously the examples
I'm giving here I just kind of said that
you understand how the transformation
works not how you would render at our
map because you clearly would not render
like a whole tile map using kind of 3d
rendering where you just you know have
everything as a separate object with a
separate material and do all that
because that's very slow but just to
give an example what you could do is
have a little for loop that let's just
say I just want to render like a bunch
of these like five of these in a row
right so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
submit and I might just not render the
the triangle for now so they're very big
right now which is fine but they're
quite big right I don't want them to be
so big so what I'm actually gonna do is
use my scale right I'm gonna make HLM
I'm at full scale I'm gonna make a scale
matrix right there's just going to
basically and we'll start off with this
because basically going to just scale
down our our cube and make it like 0.1
right so it's gonna be 0.1 of the scale
it'll used to be which is basically 10%
as big right I'm making it a lot smaller
so we've got my scale I've got my
position right and my positions gonna be
will say JM Dec 3
and then we'll just maybe we'll start it
off so how big is this gonna be right if
we look at what this is let's just work
try and work this out so it's one and a
half right so one and a half by one and
a half is how big our our actual kind of
want to make it one you know what let's
modify this and let's make it one unit
so basically the square right now is
going to have a width and height of one
unit so with that in mind this is going
to make it zero point one units right so
what I'll do is I'll set the position
the x position to be I times point one
if I do that what it's gonna do is it's
gonna space everything out by point one
that's not that great I'm gonna add
point 1 1 right so that'll leave a
little bit of a gap between each square
I'll set this to zero and that to zero
and then what I'll do is I'll construct
my matrix so this transform I'll take
down I'll put it here
this is gonna be translation of this
kind of position here right now I
multiply that scale in as well okay so
we multiply this with scale and then we
provide it with transform so now what
should happen is we should be submitting
five different squares for rendering
they're all gonna be blue and they're
gonna be kind of horizontally spaced
like going kind of from the origin
really to the right and if we don't if
they don't all fit into the screen which
they probably should but if they don't
and there should be a little smaller as
well cause it's Kelvin down if they
don't we can always move the camera into
a position that will be better okay
there we go so we've got five you can
see that all the spaced apart and we can
move just like that okay if we were to
make it
more exciting what we could do is
actually move all this over and make a
nested for loop where we go through x
and y and let's just say we ran a
recreative like 20 of these so all we
have to do is move this this way
change is 20 X so X is gonna be written
like that y is gonna be written here in
the Y position and that's that's like it
right that's all we need to do if we hit
f5 again wish if we're gonna render a
grid of 20 by 20 which is quite big
hopefully the performance will be ok
because that is like 400 of these and
yeah I mean the performance is fine so
there we go
right we can we see you see you can see
that we've actually got at our grid and
more specifically we're kind of testing
the actual we're actually testing us
being able to render objects with a
different transform so what we're doing
is we're submitting 20 different squares
here and I can put a triangle here if I
want and render that on top of
everything like we were doing before so
if I hit f5 and it can parse our code
then we have our little triangle we can
move the camera and we used to be able
to remove the we used to be able to
remove the actual squares but obviously
I took that away ok so let's clean up
this code a little bit I'm just gonna
get rid of the square move speed and all
that because that was something that we
use just for fun
and I'll probably end up believing this
kind of grid here so obviously this is
scale is something that you don't need
to recalculate all the time so you could
just make it as static if you wanted to
and then what does you know have it as a
member and then really the other thing
that we need to to recalculate is the
position but because the position
changes you do need to recalculate this
transformation matrix every time but
that's that's normal
ok that's pretty much it I hope that
makes sense now it would be really cool
if we could actually set a different
color for each of these tiles right and
then we can actually start basically
having a bit of a tile map even though
this isn't really 2d rendering as I'm
saying this is still kind of 3d
rendering it's not just 3d rendering
because it's OpenGL and OpenGL is
everything in 3d it's not that's not
what I mean what I mean is the
the technique were using to actually
render this is kind of on a per object
basis so clearly that's that's kind of
like a 3d way of doing things now what
we can do next time and what I probably
will do next time is talk about uniforms
and materials so we can set up a very
very very basic material system really
easily right and I might actually even
have next video be like a theory video
about how much hero systems work and
then we can implement a very basic one
which is all we'll need for now just to
kind of get a little bit more
flexibility and then if I do that like
basically well you can say that we're
moving hazel into an area where it could
be used to make games it could actually
be somewhat usable to do things like
that now obviously we don't have like
textures or anything like that that's
something I really want to do as well
textures but yeah like it's kind of I
don't know I feel like it's it's cool to
kind of actually have something to show
and have something that's actually
usable pretty quick because you can see
that we've got like a bit of an edge and
going on here right we're able to do all
of this stuff without touching OpenGL or
anything like that
it all kind of just works we can submit
stuff a rendering and that's all pretty
exciting so let me know what you think
about that it's probably I do want to
add in add in at least some kind of way
to set uniforms properly and also what
we end up dealing with textures soon and
then after that I think we might move
into 3d and do meshes unless people
specifically really want me to do like a
good fast blazing fast to do a 2d
renderer first because if you do it then
I might do that
anyway hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did you can hit the like button
this is kind of more of a fun video
where we actually played around with
some stuff as well as added in
transforms you can see how easy it is to
just add in the model matrix and
transform so that we can actually render
objects in different positions
you can have suppose the series back on
full session that show no huge thank you
as always to all the patrons remember
you can support the series there and get
the next video right now next time I
just say but so many things we can
explore like this is becoming difficult
for me to play and I really want to do
2d textures I really want to do a very
basic materials
just so that we can set uniforms and
textures and stuff like that properly
and then it's gonna fork off into either
a blazing fast 2d renderer and like
doing a 2d renderer properly basically
or kind of just continuing on with with
3d in which case we'll probably make
like this where where do we even start
probably we'll probably start with
meshes right so we want meshes we want
to be able to load 3d models and and
process them you know and actually apply
materials to them and render them
probably more like a 3d camera and
that's just a huge kind of thing of its
own as well
Wow let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below because this
series is up to you guys I'm making it
for you and I want to do whatever you
guys want I'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]